RECONCILIATION PACKAGE.
>> SO WE HAD MODERATE SENATORS
AGREEING WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN ON
AN INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE AND
THEN YOU HAVE GOT PROGRESSIVES
LIKE SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
SAYING WE WANT A WHOLE LOT MORE.
MAYBE AS MUCH AS $6 TRILLION
WITH THAT BRING IN OUR PANEL.
MAVERICK, THE BIOGRAPHY OF
THOMAS SEOUL.
PANEL, WELCOME.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Mike: SO, CONGRESSMAN, HAROLD
FORD JR., WHAT DO WE HAVE GOING
ON ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF
THINGS ARE THEY TRYING TO KEEP
THRAWRK FOR HAVING ME.
I LOOK FORWARD TO READING THE
NEW BOOK.
FROM MITCH McCONNELL TO
SENATOR SANDERS.
IT REMINDED ME OF TWO THINGS
THIS EFFORT TO GET BIPARTISAN
AGREEMENT AROUND INFRASTRUCTURE
IS REALLY A TEST WHETHER
BIPARTISAN REMAINS A PART OF THE
RELEVANT VERNACULAR OR CURRENT
VERNACULAR.
HOLPP IT DOES.
WE DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY,
LEADERS IN WASHINGTON DON'T HAVE
THE LUXURY IN A DEEPLY, DEEPLY
DIVIDED COUNTRY AND A COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE LOST TRUST AND
CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT TO
ALWAYS SAY NO.
I THINK WHEN YOU FIND
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERALS
THOUGH THE ON THE EACH SIDE AND
PARTY FINDING ISSUE OR
DIFFERENCE WITH A COMPROMISE OR
SOME SORT OF BIPARTISAN
COMPROMISE, THAT'S WHEN
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO DIG DOWN
AND LISTEN AND HOPE THAT THE
CONGRESS CAN MOVE FORWARD.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
HAPPY WITH ALL OF THIS,
REPUBLICANS ARE CLEARLY NOT.
THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO REDO AND
STRENGTHEN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THIS GIVES US A HUGE DOWN
BASEMENT TO DO THAT OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
>> Mike: I ASKED MEMBERSHIP
McCONNELL ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IT CAN BEST BE DESCRIBED AS A
TALE OF TWO PRESS CONFERENCES
AFTER THE FIRST ONE, THE
PRESIDENT WALKS OUT WITH A
BIPARTISAN GROUP AND BLESSES AN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL THAT MANY OF
MY MEMBERS ARE QUITE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT AND THEN AFTER ALL OF
THOSE PEOPLE DEPART THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE PRESIDENT GOES OUT
FOR THE SECOND PRESS CONFERENCE
AND SAYS UNLESS YOU PASS MY TAX
BILL I WON'T SIGN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
GONE FROM OPTIMISM TO PESSIMISM
AS A RESULT OF PRESIDENT'S
SECOND PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> Mike: MOLLIE, HOW DO YOU SEE
IT?
>> WELL, IT WAS A VERY
INTERESTING DAY IN WASHINGTON.
IT STARTS OUT WITH THIS VERY BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THERE HAD BEEN
A BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SHOULD BE ONE OF
THE EASIEST THINGS TO GET
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT ON AND THE
FACT THAT IT'S TAKEN THIS LONG
IS NOT A GREAT SIGN.
BUT HERE YOU HAD THESE PEOPLE
REALLY OPERATING IN SEEMINGLY
GOOD FAITH TO GET TOGETHER ON A
BIPARTISAN BILL.
THEN NANCY PELOSI BLOWS IT UP BY
SAYING SHE WON'T ALLOW IT TO
HAPPEN UNLESS THERE IS THIS
MASSIVE SPENDING PACKAGE THAT'S
BEEN A NONSTARTER FOR A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS OR EVEN JUST PEOPLE
REMOTELY CONCERNED ABOUT FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH THERE ARE
FEW AND FAR BETWEEN BE IN THIS
TOWN.
BUT THEN PRESIDENT BIDEN GIVES
THIS PRESS CONFERENCE WHERE HE
SAYS HE AGREES WITH NANCY
PELOSI.
IT WAS UTTERLY BIZARRE.
AND THE PRESS CONFERENCE BE IN
GENERAL WAS WEIRD.
HE KEPT ON WHISPERING WEIRD
THINGS LIKE WHEN HE BLAMED
BUSINESSES FOR THE PROBLEM THEY
ARE HAVING WITH BEING ABLE TO
HIRE PEOPLE.
HE SAID THAT THEY NEED TO
COMPETE WITH THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS TAKING THEIR MONEY
TO PAY PEOPLE NOT TO WORK.
AND THAT IF THEY WANT PEOPLE TO
WORK THEY SHOULD JUST PAY THEM
MORE.
IT WAS VERY ODD.
AND I THINK IT WAS DISCONCERTING
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE TO SAY WHAT
IS GOING ON HERE.
>> Mike: JASON, DO THEY GET
SOMETHING DONE OR DOES THIS ALL
BLOW UP IN THE HOT SUMMER?
>> I KIND OF HOPE IT BLOWS UP,
MIKE, FRANKLY.
I THINK THAT MITCH McCONNELL
IS WISE TO BE SKEPTICAL OF THIS.
BARRY GOLDWATER URGED
REPUBLICANS TO OFFER A CHOICE
NOT SIMPLY AN ECHO.
AND I THINK THAT THE SENATORS
PUSHING FOR THIS ARE REALLY
OFFERING AN ECHO.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT HOW MUCH
IS BEING SPENT.
THEY DON'T DON'T CARE WHETHER WE
CAN PAY FOR IT THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY IS SPENT ON HEIR
PRIORITIES AS WELL AS DEMOCRATIC
PRIORITIES.
I THINK THE VOTERS DESERVE
BETTER THAN THAT.
THIS IS PART OF A MUCH LARGER
BIDEN AGENDA TO TAKE US BACK TO
WORLD WAR II LEVEL SPENDING,
MIKE.
I MEAN, THE LAST TIME I CHECKED
WE WERE NOT AT WAR, LET ALONE A
WAR ON THE SCALE OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON 80 YEARS AGO.
THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT.
I DON'T THINK THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WOULD HAVE SPLIT THE
SENATE 50/50 IF THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANTED MAKE MIKE OKAY.
TO VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS GOING
TO THE BORDER TOMORROW TO EL
PASO.
LET'S PLAY THIS CLIP AND I WILL
HAVE YOU ALL RESPOND.
>> WAS IT IMPORTANT FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE TO HAVE HER SEEN AT
THE BORDER BEFORE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS THIS NEXT
WEEK.
>> WE HAD A DISCUSSION IN THE
GOVERNMENT ABOUT WHEN IMPORTANT
GO TO THE BORDER.
>> SHE IS GOING WHERE IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE SEEN ACTIVE
CROSSING.
THEY DON'T WANT THEM CROSSING
BEHIND HER ACTIVE SHOT.
IMAGINE IF SHE WANTED TO GET TO
THE HOT SPOT AND LANDED IN
BOSTON SHE WOULDN'T BE IN THE
RIGHT SPOT.
IF SHE IS GOING TO DO IT DO IT
RIGHT AND DON'T LAUGH IT OFF.
IT'S A SERIOUS SITUATION.
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
>> HAROLD, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IS A COUPLE THINGS.
I THINK OUR FOREIGN POLICY, WE
HAVE TO BEGIN TO LOOK AT THE
BORDER AS A NATIONAL SECURITY
CHALLENGE AS PART OF A BROADER
FOREIGN POLICY CHALLENGE.
WHEN YOU APPROACH A BIG REFORM
BILL WITH INFRASTRUCTURE
IMMIGRATION ON EITHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE, YOU HAVE GOT TO GET
TWO THINGS RIGHT.
NUMBER ONE THE SUBSTANCE, AND
NUMBER TWO THE POLITICS.
I THINK VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS
HAS GOTTEN SOME OF THE SUBSTANCE
AND NOT A LOT OF IT RIGHT WITH
THE WAY SHE HAS LOOKED AT THE
ROOT CAUSES.
HOPEFULLY THIS ACTS AS
ACCELERANT HER TRAVELING TO THE
BORDER AND VISITING THERE.
IT IS A CRISES AT THE BORDER.
I MIGHT ADD AND A MOMENT OF
LEVITY HERE AND PERHAPS
LIGHTNESS HERE, VISITING THE
BORDER WOULD SOLVE OUR BORDER
CHALLENGE AND BORDER IMMIGRATION
CHALLENGE, THEN WE WOULD HAVE
SOLVED THIS PROBLEM A LONG, LONG
TIME AGO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP VISITED.
EVEN CRUZ AND GRAHAM AND ALL THE
SENATORS WHO DO ALL THIS BIG
COMPLAINING, THEY HAVE ALL GONE
DOWN AND WE HAVE NOT SOLVED
ANYTHING.
THIS HAS TO BE VIEWED AS PART OF
A LONG-TERM SOLUTION.
BIG VIOLATION TO A LONG-TERM
PROBLEM.
REMEMBER, THE LAST TIME WE HAD
IMMIGRATION REFORM IN THIS
COUNTRY WAS 35 YEARS AGO AND
THAT PRESIDENT WAS RONALD REAGAN
A LOT HAS CHANGED.
A LOT HAS GOTTEN WORSE.
WE ARE GOING TO NEED A BIG
PACKAGE TO GET IT RIGHT.
>> Mike: SO THE VICE PRESIDENT
IS GOING TO EL PASO.
SHE IS NOT GOING TO THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY OR HOLDING
FACILITY IN DONNA, TEXAS,
MOLLIE, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT IS GOOD TO GO TO THE BORDER.
IT'S GOOD THAT SHE WAS FINALLY
PRESSURED INTO GOING TO THE
BORDER BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS VISITING.
BUT IT'S NOT SUFFICIENT TO GO
DOWN THERE, HAVE A LAUGH, AND
KEEP THINGS GOINGS THE SAME WAY
THAT THEY ARE.
IT WOULD BE BETTER IF SHE
VISITED FORT BLISS.
ONE OF THESE CONTRACTOR
FACILITIES WHERE 2,000 TEENAGERS
ARE BEING HELD WHERE THERE ARE
LIES OUTBREAKS AND STREP AND FLU
AND COVID-19 AND THE FOOD IS
SUBSTANDARD WHERE SHE ACTUALLY
SAW THE PAIN CAUSED BY THE
POLICIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS BECAUSE
OF THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
A SERIES OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
DECISION NOT TO TURN ANYONE AWAY
AND EVEN NOW WELCOMING PEOPLE
NOT JUST UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
BUT SINGLE PEOPLE, FAMILIES, AND
MAKING A VISIT TO A PLACE WHERE
THERE IS NOT MUCH OF A PROBLEM
ISN'T GOING TO DO ANYTHING.
YOU NEED ACTUALLY HAVE HER
UNDERSTAND THE PROBLEM, THE PAIN
AND EVERY -- ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
CAUSED BY HAVING AN OPEN, POROUS
BORDER OR ELSE IT'S NOT WORTH A
TRIP AT ALL.
>> Mike: JASON, DO YOU SEE A
POLICY CHANGE COMING SOON?
>> I'M NOT SO SURE.
I THINK THIS IS MORE ABOUT
OPTICS.
I SEE THIS AS PART OF WHAT WAS
GOING ON EARLIER THIS WEEK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S WE HAVE A
VIOLENT CRIME PROBLEM IN OUR BIG
CITIES THIS PRESIDENT CAME IN
AND THOUGHT HE WOULD DO THE
OPPOSITE OF EVERYTHING DONALD
TRUMP WAS DOING.
IF TRUMP HAD PLAYED UP VIOLENT
CRIME HE WOULD PLAY IT DOWN.
IF TRUMP PLAYED UP A BORDER
PROBLEM HE WOULD PLAY IT DOWN.
THESE ARE REAL PROBLEMS AND NOW
HE IS SUDDENLY REALIZING THAT
AND HE HAS TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THEM.
THEY ARE PLAYING CATCH UP HERE.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT, TO THE
VOTING RIGHTS BILL I ASKED
SENATOR McCONNELL ABOUT THAT
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
KEEP ON TALKING ABOUT IT, WE
WOULD LIKE TO KEEP ON TALKING
ABOUT IT, TOO.
THERE IS NO VOTER SUPPRESSION
GOING ON IN ANY STATE IN AMERICA
AND THE BILL THEY WERE TRYING TO
PASS WOULD HAVE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
SPENT ON POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS,
WOULD TURN THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMISSION FROM A JUDGE INTO A
PROSECUTOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, MAKE IT
UNBALANCED.
AND PREVENT PHOTO I.D. AT THE
POLL, SOMETHING SUPPORTED BY 80%
OF AMERICANS.
SO, IF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
KEEP ON TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL,
SO DO WE.
>> Mike: ALL RIGHT.
WE GOT LESS THAN A MINUTE LEFT.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GO AROUND
THE HORN REAL FAST.
HAROLD, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> LOOK, WE HAD THE BIGGEST
TURNOUT.
WE HAD THE LEAST PROBLEMS EVER
IN A FEDERAL ELECTION.
WHY WE WOULD MAKE ANY CHANGES.
THESE STATES ARE MAKING CHANGES
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
TRYING TO CORRECT OR TRYING TO
PREVENT THOSE CHANGES FROM
HURTING VOTER TURFOUT.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE AND HOPEFULLY
THEY FIGURE THIS THING OUT.
>> Mike: MOLLIE?
>> IT IS NOT TRUE THAT THIS WAS
AN ELECTION WITHOUT PROBLEMS.
IN FACT, AS PEOPLE HAVE MOVED TO
MAIL-IN BALLOTING, PEOPLE NEED
TO HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST THAT PEOPLE ARE FREE TO
VOTE BUT ALSO THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT TO CHEAT.
SO THIS IS A VERY SALIENT ISSUE
AND REPUBLICANS ARE FINDING THAT
DESPITE ALL OF THE PROPAGANDA
PRESS IN FAVOR OF DEMOCRATS PLAN
IT'S NOT VERY POPULAR WITH THE
PEOPLE.
SO THEY ARE HAPPY TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THE VOTERS REALLY DO
PREVENT BASIC ELECTION INTEGRITY
MEASURES SUCH AS VOTER I.D.
>> Mike: JASON, FINAL THOUGHT
FROM YOU?
>> THERE IS NO VOTING RIGHTS
PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE IS RECORD TURNOUT AMONG
HOME INVASIONS AND HISPANICS.
AMONG BLACKS THE THIRD HIGHEST
TURNOUT AFTER 2000 WILL AND
2012.
AND OF COURSE BARACK OBAMA WAS
ON THE BALLOT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT VOTING RIGHT